la kermesse socialiste a choisi cécile
comme chaque année depuis 1973 les
militants ont mis en place leur stand
pour la fête de la rose même si la foule
d'autres fois n'est pas au rendez-vous
et quelques sympathisants présents
veulent quand même croire en ce
rassemblement quinquennaux de hollande
nous a un petit peu déçu je viens de
dire
mais vient encore de l'espoir parce que
c'est à nous de revenir des activités
militantes et aussi à proposer des idées
qu'ils puissent se construire un projet
nouveau pour la france dont on a besoin
pour la gauche et pour la france sur les
étals il reste encore des traces des
beaux jours
ce wpt arnaud montebourg ou encore
ségolène royal rassemblé plus de 5000
personnes autour d'eux chance mais pour
cette 46e édition seuls 200 ont répondu
à l'appel
l'organisateur de la fête reconnaît la
dispersion de la gauche mais reste
optimiste
mathias est trop content parce que
certes la gauche est en miettes certes
la gauche ne va pas bien mais il ya
quand même un fort besoin de gauche dans
ce pays
face aux attaques tous les jours de la
politique de d'emmanuel macron de
recentralisation
au programme de la journée et tables
rondes conférences et signature
traditionnelle du livre d'or avec un
rêve dans toutes les têtes
reconstruire la gauche unie telle est
possible elle viendra tous ceux qui
résisteront essaieront de mettre des
coins pour empêcher l'unité cela ils
passeront à la trappe
parce que l'histoire ira vers l'unité à
gauche quoi qu'il arrive
j'étais à marseille pour la france a
soumis vendredi je suis à frangy
aujourd'hui avec des socialistes ou des
gens qui sont hors du parti socialiste
mon rôle au sein de génération c'est de
pouvoir continuer à dialoguer avec
toutes les forces de gauche
pourtant toutes les nuances de rose ne
sont pas présentes aucun représentant de
la france un soumise par exemple alors
pour l'année prochaine tous ici espère
redonner à leurs fleurs sont anciens et
club